this is a production of Cornell
University today I'm going to give you a
little bit of a couple different things
first is a bit of an overview of the
cider market kind of understanding why
it's important to be researching hard
cider right now secondly a bit of a
travelogue from some visits I made to
the UK a couple years ago to understand
a little bit about their cider economy
their site or supply chain how they're
producing site are there and then
finished off talking about some of our
ongoing research and trying to draw some
threads between historic trends in cider
production and what we're currently
doing to try to try to push the industry
forward so it's about the apples and so
I'm a horticulturalist and in fact you
know we're trying to make the case that
we can be we meaning New York State can
be the the epicenter for cider
production in the u.s. because of our of
our market because of our historic apple
production here in the state and because
of the large consumer base that is in
close proximity to our main apple
growing regions so just a little bit of
terminology and defining terms and for
those of you from overseas whether it's
from the UK or New Zealand when people
said cider it was understood that you're
talking about an alcoholic beverage here
in the States when we say cider people
think that brown cloudy juice that you'd
buy from the Cornell orchards for
example or from you know any other cider
apple producer you get with the cider
doughnut you know in the fall so when I
say cider today I'm always talking about
the alcoholic beverage which we in the
States usually referred to as hard cider
so it comes from apples right so here's
cider who's a cloudy juice or it can be
filtered
they don't drink it as much apple juice
overseas that was one of the really
interesting things I learned about it
maybe a little bit more in recent
but historically they didn't drink this
really clear juice that we grew up on
our you know the kids in the US grew up
on so hard cider fermented great yeast
fermentation taking the sugar converting
it to alcohol legally defined as being
below eight-and-a-half percent ABV
alcohol by volume so by comparison wines
or I mean a beer is anywhere from like
three point two four like the
mass-produced beers up to six seven for
some of the kind of more craft beers
have some cider Nina so and wine
typically is you know somewhere between
11 and 15 percent depending on the style
so cider kind of hits that middle mark
it's it's right in between ranges
anywhere from five to eight and a half
is pretty typical they even have cutoff
is not based on the chemical composition
you know the sugar content of the apples
as much as it is for regulatory reasons
historic reasons and the cider industry
is continually trying to push that
envelope higher but gets a lot of
pushback from the wine industry that
wants it doesn't want ciders to be have
the higher alcohol content
if cider is allowed to get oxidated and
there's a seat of actor around a trace
the vinegar and then there's a whole
bunch of products that can be made from
distillation Oh Davi is a clear spirit
which comes right off of the still very
strong
if you aged it in barrels oak barrels
you'll make brandy so Calvados is the
traditional apple brandy it's made in in
France and we have some producers here
in the States now and then if you take
your Calvados your brandy and you mix it
with with some of the hard cider you'll
get pummel which is this really nice
aperitif there's also this product that
we have a history of making in the u.s.
called Applejack and this is where you
take the fermented cider and yet led to
freeze in the in your you know in your
backyard or wherever and you freeze or
distel distill it and that concentrates
the alcohols now so it concentrates the
ethanol which is what a lot of people
were hoping to do but it's also
concentrating those other alcohols that
have that were naturally made through
the fermentation process but are very
dangerous to drink for human health
reasons so if you're a hobbyist you can
make 100 gallons for your own use or 200
in your entire household and so when I
talk about cider apples I'm talking
about very specific class of apples
these are apples that have in particular
high tannin concentration so tannins are
a subset it's a functionally defined
subset of polyphenols that are defined
because they used to tan leather you
know turn leather brown but now we think
of tannins in in terms of food as those
chemicals that lend themselves towards
bitterness or astringency okay and so
we'll taste them in a few minutes it's
what allows the craft end of the cider
industry to make these more wine like
products that have a lot more mouthfeel
to them are the tannins so that's a
really important thing and it's what we
don't have commonly and I'll show you
the data in a few slides that we don't
have very high levels of in our culinary
apples right because these are fairly
unpleasant compounds to eat if you have
them in too high a concentration so they
have these four classifications as
originally classified probably in the
late 1800s but first documented in about
1910 and it's from the long Ashton
Research Center which is now a defunct
research centre in the United Kingdom
but they came up with these his classes
bitter sweet bitter sharps sharps and
sweets based on their percent of tannins
and then the other chemical group there
were classifying apples with was malic
acid so if it's above a certain
threshold then it's a sharp apple and
below that it would be a sweet apple I
think I see that certain of these
cultivars okay so what does a crabapple
you're asking
so animal so a crabapple is basically
mostly a species a mallow species so
Malus domestica is the apple you're
familiar right it's a hybridized apple
for a male severe CI from region of we
now know as Kazakhstan and then it
hybridized with malice of estrus with
Celestra s-- which is a european
crabapple there's other hybridization
events and other domestication it's a
kind of a complicated story than that
but that's the basis of it anything that
is not doméstica so any of these species
or even hybrids are typically called
crab apples so we have several malice
species that are native to the US we
refer to them as crab apples so it's not
a very precise term but it's what we're
familiar with and and any apple that
contains sugar can be fermented and
turned into cider so there's no reason
why other malice species cannot be used
for cider production so a little bit
about the markets the United Kingdom is
the biggest market in the world about
45% of all cider is consumed there the
rest of Europe consumes about no 20% and
the u.s. is about 10% of the of the
world cider consumption but it's growing
significantly and so there is no about
just shy of a thousand producers
throughout the US every state I've
worked with producers in Hawaii Texas
and Alaska now so not areas that are
traditionally known as Apple producing
regions or making cider and they're
making about 50 million gallons a year
it's kind of edging up from that a
little bit those last year I was able to
get data from the TTB
and you can see there's a high
concentration of cider producers with
these little balloon dots in the
northeastern US primarily in our apple
growing region along the Great Lakes and
then also in Washington State well and I
forgot to sent it say very importantly
New York is the has more cider producers
in any other state we used to have a lot
more and Michigan is now just one
producer behind us
we had very favorable legislation early
on by the New York state government that
called the farm cidery license that made
a pretty low barrier for entry for
people to open up cider ease and it
allowed a really quick increase in the
number of producers other states have
followed that trend in Michigan in there
so why are we talking about cider well
the growth is been very impressive
tenfold in the last ten years if we were
to do a little back of the napkin
calculation on it and assume you get
about three gallons of cider in a bushel
bushels like a 42-pound box you know
those wooden or our cardboard boxes
that's a bushel of apples you get a
three gallons out of that then the
amount of cider being made in in 2014
and 15 would have been equivalent to
seven percent of the entire US apple
crop so that's pretty impressive but
it's not in fact seven percent of the
u.s. apple crop because a lot of the
producers are importing apple juice
concentrate from places like China
Poland Brazil and even some bittersweet
apple juice concentrate is now coming
into the u.s. from England and France
and you can kind of see you know it's a
relatively small market share compared
to wine so 1.3 1.5 billion right now is
the size of the cider market beer is the
largest alcohol industry in the u.s.
about a hundred billion dollars in wines
about 35 billion so the trends are that
worried there's not there's not been an
increase in alcohol consumption
okay so increases in one of these
segments one of these you know types of
products is means that it's pulling
consumers from another one so side where
consumers are coming a lot from the
craft beer into craft beer consumers
right people who are used to
experimenting with you know all sorts of
different kinds of flavoring different
beers
Styles are starting to buy crafts ciders
less so from the wine consumers but
we're starting to see some wine
consumers now buying ciders so that's
where it's going
there's also been a bit of a decrease in
cider sales and consumption from the
last couple years and I'll talk about
that in a minute so a little bit more
about just trying to understand like
where deciders fit in if we're comparing
it to just in New York state between
cider ease wineries and breweries
there's about a hundred in cider ease in
New York they are we have about 400 we
have about 40,000 acres of apples but
only 200 acres of cider apples we did
some work with harvest New York to try
to understand you know the scale of the
industry and they're making about 50
million gallons a year wineries and so
it seems like a lot well you know we had
a saturation point for cider ease here
but then if you look at wineries there's
450 in the state there's over 200 in the
Finger Lakes alone and there's 400
breweries in the state in terms of
overall production of the fruit there's
a lot more apple acres in the state then
then wine grape acres but only 200 of
our apple acres are really cider apples
and then breweries has kind of a similar
issue with the supply chain right
there's 400 breweries in the state but
not very much in the way of production
of hops or barley in the state and so
for these craft or a farm liquor license
so the craft I'm sorry the farm side
relations or the farm brewery license
you need to be using New York State
grown ingredients okay so for the cider
you're supposed to be sourcing 100
percent apples from New York State to
have a farm cidery license for the
breweries they were supposed to
initially be getting their raw
ingredients from New York State but we
just don't have it right we have apples
we may not have the special
but we have apples but we do not have
the hops or the barley acreage there's
some increases in there but it's
happening very very slowly so is there a
cider bubble there was a bit of a
downturn in the market 20 16 and 17 and
I think a lot of that was because
there's such a rapid increase a lot of
that increase can be attributed to one
company which is angry orchard and they
have about 60% of the market share for
cider in the US right now they were not
making cider ten years ago right so
angry orchard is owned by Austin beer
company which also makes anybody know
Sam Adams yep and Mike's Hard Lemonade
and they have a hard seltzer product now
so there you know exploring different
different segments of the alcohol market
but there but their cider went from zero
to 60 they increased and they kind of
took the foot off the pedal a little bit
in 2016 and 17 just to try to understand
where they're at see if they wanted to
continue to grow or if they you know
we're kind of at that point where they
felt like they had market saturation and
there aren't going to be any more cider
consumers in what they had but something
changed and so that's her first tasting
today and Millennials love pink
apparently and so about 2016 2017
there's a huge increase in rosy wines
and then 2017 and 18 we saw the same
thing happen insiders and so the market
has had a huge uptick in the last year
year and a half
primarily because of of rosy ciders so
if you haven't had it yet you can take a
taste of it it's a largely made from
apple juice concentrate they do use some
red flesh apples there are some apples
have anthocyanins in the flesh as well
as on the peel or at the red color its
anthocyanins but you know if we have 200
acres of cider apples in the state we
maybe we have 200 trees of red fleshed
apples being grown commercially a lot of
planting going on a lot of nurseries are
being asked for red fleshed apples right
now because of this and because this is
seeing such a big increase in the market
share but consumers buy with their eyes
and pink is in right now okay so let's
talk a little bit about cider from other
parts of the world and so in 2017 two
years ago or so year and a half ago I
got to make a couple trips to the United
Kingdom I went first with this group of
folks here this is a nonprofit based in
the Hudson River Valley they got funding
from angry orchard they worked with the
cider Association and it's a group of
cider apple growers and cider producers
and we got to tour through cider apple
orchards in the UK and taste some ciders
as well but mostly we were there to look
at at their production their apple
orchards so just by comparison between
the UK the US and New York now if we
look at domestic sales I said it's the
largest cider market in the world
they're about 4 billion US is 1.5
billion and so it's it's growing
significantly New York maybe about 44
million in terms of domestic sales their
acreage they have about about 35 36
thousand acres of apples in the UK and
total about half of those are cider
apples okay in the u.s. we have about
325 thousand acres of apples we have no
idea how many cider apple acres are in
the US there's no surveying happening at
the national scale in New York we have
about 40,000 acres of apples total maybe
hundred 200 acres
cider apples so you can get some
relative sense of their industry it's
huge rate they're the biggest cider
market in the world and they grow a lot
of apples specifically for for making
hard cider so this is what their
orchards look like it's they call them
bush orchards they're planted a fairly
wide spacing this is kind of a spacing
that we don't use very much anymore in
the US 8 by 8 feet between trees 18 feet
between rows our growers now are
planting trees as close to a foot and a
half apart and 11 feet between rows okay
so significantly more three four times
as many trees per acre they're using
dabeh net and michelin primarily for
their varieties they've kind of figured
out what two varieties work they're
using semi dwarfing rootstocks and the
key point is that they're mechanically
harvesting and they do this through a
series of different technical events
including clean tree so it's a nut
producers in the US will do this great a
lot of our nuts are shaken and then
drops to the ground about a single
shaker will go through and do about ten
acres and then they go through with
these sweeps
you kill the apples are harvested ground
harvested apples whole food seat is
fated that could clip this we're doing a
lot of work and talking to colleagues
around the u.s. about and they kinda is
kind of like a anybody's familiar with
potato harvesting this is kind of
similar to the belts they used for
picking up potatoes off the ground just
kind of - roller conveyor belts that go
through and just basically smoosh the
apples and pick them up
you know we'll go up in very severe
belts and then put into don't have to
pick them by hand have to be very
delicate with them and in fact it's
quite the opposite this is just some
different machines that are used in
different parts of the country depending
on the scale these things were like
garbage truck size right for some of the
bigger operations this is a one that I
saw they were custom making at Somerset
farm machinery it's a half million
dollar machine that was being custom
designed for a French cider apple
cooperative then the store the apples
Chris this is this is post-harvest
storage for cider apples in the UK so
they put them in these clamps they call
them a desk what is it East keep saying
they're clamps and so this basically is
these concrete bunkers and so they'll
pick them up they'll dump them in there
and sometimes they'll sit on the ground
for a week or two and then they'll sit
in these piles here for a couple more
weeks before they get picked up with a
front-end loader and then driven in a
truck to the cider mill so this truck
gets into the cider mill and breaks the
mill then the operation is down so
they're very condensed harvest window to
three months out of the years when they
do all the harvesting and processing but
at that point they are not storing the
apples for any length of time like we do
in our industry for Fresh Market apples
and now we are for cider apples which is
really interesting and it
some research avenues for us because
nowhere else in the world do they stick
apples into a cold storage unit and then
pull them out an exciter in June or July
all right they make all their cider in
October November and December and you
can see what happens to the fruit after
all of these operations pretty ugly and
this was after this photo here was after
the two guys that they put on the line
because I was there that day we're
pulling out the bad apples okay so
that's kind of a little bit of an
overview of what I get to see you in
England and but I really enjoyed those
trips it was really pretty remarkable to
learn how twenty thousand acres of
apples are being harvested when we only
have 200 and we hand harvest ours so a
little bit about my cider research
program you know I kind of have been
addressing the cider industry from a
number of different angles done a lot of
work looking at the economics of it
because that was kind of the first
question I got from growers was is it
worthwhile to plant these right so an
apple orchard cost somewhere around 20
thousand dollars an acre to plant so
it's a very expensive proposition and so
if an apple grower is deciding should I
plant Honey Crisp or Snapdragon or Gala
or dabba net or Michelin right so we
have done a lot of work with the
economics and trying to figure that out
this was some work I did when I was at
Virginia and we did find some
profitability if they were able to get
15 dollars a bushel which is kind of a
price at galas would sell for in the
market these days and they had a fairly
low input type of system from we also
made these customizable spreadsheets
that allowed growers to go in and figure
out their own costs which are really
nice but we we found that as much as I
would go out to extension meetings and
talk to growers about how to use these
very few of them probably did
the room right there just it was just
hard to you know outside of a handful to
get them to actually go ahead and do
that but you know they're they're nice
features but because we developed this
custom tool it allowed us to go ahead
and and run some additional model so we
found you know first of all in Virginia
there's profitability in it
I got collected a lot of data when I was
in England and I ran their budget on it
and so this is for a typical Bush type
of orchard that's that's being produced
in the UK this is a what's called a
enterprise budget so after 25 years it's
looking at your profitability so
anything above zero means you're
profitable so these orchards because
they're getting very little price it's a
commodity for them to sell these apples
they have these long-term contracts with
the main producers bohmers buys about
half of all the cider apples in the UK
bohmers is the largest cider producer in
the world they're owned by Heineken and
they don't pay very much 390 a bushel
great so that's well below our prices
for even processing fruit and clearly
for them it's not a profitable system
there's other incentives there's other
reasons why some of these orchards can
be profitable there is actually animal
cropping systems in here that Gris sheep
and um they get payment for just keeping
the land in agricultural production but
but the orchard themselves if you're
just gonna do the orchard would not be
profitable so some key differences when
we start thinking about this and and how
can we be more profitable in the u.s. so
just trying to understand a little bit
about the UK system versus what we're
doing here so they're getting three 3:39
i say here you know crisis we're varying
a little bit in the UK our apple growers
are getting between fifteen and thirty
dollars a bushel for cider apples
because we have they have a huge supply
I mean they have a huge supply and
kind of you know their demand is kind of
maxed out whereas we have a huge demand
for this fruit and almost no supply
right 200 acres of cider apples in the
US and in New York State very low input
systems no trellis system their
irrigation they don't spray very much
and they're mechanically harvesting
right so they're not having that what is
the number one cost for most orchards
which is hand harvesting the fruit right
it's a huge cost as well as all of the
social issues that go with and political
issues that go with having to get a huge
labor force to pick the fruit so like I
said we found that while I kept talking
about these Excel spreadsheets that
growers can use themselves they really
weren't using them too much so my hard
wit knickerbocker who graduated in 2015
from from AG econ here and at Cornell
and he went around and did case studies
of six different cider apple orchards in
New York State and so collected all the
information about their cost of
production their yields their expected
returns etc we found that you know these
operations varied widely there was
organic they were conventional someone
were trying to do kind of traditional
processing orchards some were doing high
density systems but five out of the six
were profitable after the after twenty
five years and really most of them were
hitting profitability in this kind of
spot between six and eight years where
they're crossing that that line or six
and nine years somewhere in there for
being profitable except for this one
orchard here orchard six and that's
because they were using the most
sophisticated orchard systems available
planting the trees basically very close
together
irrigation had very high labor costs and
then selling the fruit basically as
processing fruit and it didn't add up
right I mean that kind of makes sense so
but a good take-home and we published
this in the free quarterly which is like
the trade magazine for the growers in
the state so that they can understand a
little bit about what they're getting
into it yeah
it's not doing very well mm-hmm what was
the is doing very well so the one that
that is orchard one here that had the
highest profitability kind of really
almost have seen an unbelievable numbers
and at pie say if we you know so for
most days orchards were able to collect
empirical data for years one two three
maybe some of them we got out to about
year five empirical data and then these
orchards are also new that we're doing a
lot of assumptions for the rest of the
time and that orchard was assuming the
highest prices
kind of even better than Honey Crisp
into today prices for cider fruit and
was also I think under estimating their
labor costs but this is their
information and this these are case
studies you know so we're just kind of
putting in their story so and in fact
it's a good lead-in because if we if we
took an average price and so we did we
did some survey work in New York we also
looked at surveys in the Pacific
Northwest the Upper Midwest Vermont and
Virginia and found that the average
price for cider apples was probably
closer to about thirty five cents and
and so when we did that that orchard
that was the most profitable using their
numbers kind of came out to be in the
middle of the pack when we use these
more standardized numbers and in fact
the orchard that became the most
profitable was the one that most
resembled a processing orchard with
wider spacing all right so let's taste a
few apples I've got two here going
around and I'll just gonna pass them
around the yellow one is called middle D
or gold medal in French and then the red
apple is called porters perfection so
the way to taste a cider apple
take a bite and chew it up but don't
swallow it yet
and then take that hope and push it
against a roof of your mouth
and you should be able to get those
cannons right bitterness and a
particularly astringency right that that
tactile sensation of dryness chalkiness
kind of unpleasant sometimes we call
them spitters right I have a garbage can
here but you guys don't and then poor
does perfection is a bitter so that's a
bittersweet is modality orb and then
poor does perfection is a bitter sharp I
mean it has both tannins and acidity it
also has this really cool feature which
is called Polycarp II and so the fruit
will double and this happens during
flower bud development in the previous
season cherries do this a lot under heat
stress not too many culinary apples do
this
some mostly doubles sometimes triples
there's a few in the basket going around
too so Polycarp E is the word of the day
so we did some work trying to understand
a little bit about what's in the US
market right now that's being grown and
let's see do you guys get the second
cider yet yeah yeah okay so a second
cider then is you can taste the Apple
and then it's called Eve cidery it's a
local producer and about 60% of that
juice is bitter bitter sharp juice is
there any more of it and so you should
be able to now that you've tasted the
apples understand a little bit about the
tannins in there so if we look at the
apples and a lot of these are the kind
of traditional fresh market apples and
processing apples that you'd find in the
mid-atlantic or northeastern US and a
lot of them are over this threshold of
4.5 to be a sharp apple with just a few
exceptions few G Ida Reds and Red
Delicious and so we've got plenty of
acidity in terms of like if you think
about it in terms of the palette of
apples available but we don't have is
very much in the way of a phenolic so
these tannins right so these are the
same apples from this
and you can see our threshold of being
bitter would be up close to 2,000 and
you can see it most of these are well
below that level all right so these are
the exception of a few heirloom
varieties like Harrison and Crabbe that
have you know a fair amount of tannin
but nothing near as much as the porters
perfection or the modality or that are
going around so you should really taste
those tannins now after having that
Apple should be really apparent to you
really different kind of product um you
know different market share different
consumer type I'd say so we've been
doing a lot of work we've been planting
different variety trials we've been
importing apples from different parts of
the world to get them here a lot of them
are flawed all right so look at these
things they split open these things rot
before you can pick them they give all
sorts of disease problems this is fire
blight a bacterial disease it'll just
pretty much outright kill the tree a lot
of the cider apples are really prone to
that rots blind wood which is these long
sections of branches without any flower
buds on them or even any vegetative buds
really small fruit size which is okay if
you're mechanically harvesting but not
so much if you're going to be if you're
going to be a hand harvesting right it
takes a lot of time and effort to and
harvest very small fruit like that so
you know the growers say okay we need
this elite list and we've come up with a
list of cultivars that we think do well
in our climate but I also think that's
really important to think about
maximizing the genetic diversity and
really the flavor diversity of cider
apples right so apples you know 7,000
probably closer to 14,000 named
varieties of apples and and to say well
we should have six or three which is
what the nurseries and some of the big
scale growers say they want you know I
you know I I understand that from a
commercial perspective but also greatly
appreciate the diversity and we have
this amazing resource it been
Niva called the plant genetics resource
unit it's a part of the ARS within USDA
and their job is to preserve genetic
diversity of different crops so the one
in Geneva is based all on apples they
have about 5000 unique sessions did
unique genotypes there so it's Nathan in
the bottom right and bottom left is
David who have both worked on this
project and a lot of my lab group have
worked on different parts of this
project over the last couple years we're
looking at about 300 in a little bit
more than 300 different sessions from
there from largely from the UK France in
the US but also you can kind of see
we're looking at stuff widely from
different countries as well as a number
of quote-unquote crabapples so some
hybrids malla severe CI which is the
main progenitor species of our culinary
apple as well as some of these other
species here to say if any of these can
be used for production so if we were to
look at it on the scale of the long
ashton scale in terms of a bitter sweet
bitter sharp etc from our 2017 harvest
we found about 30% to be bittersweet you
know and that's because it's a
self-selected pool and 13 to be bitter
sharp and I think those bitter sharps
are the ones that are gonna be really
interesting these red dots here to the
cider industry cuz they have the ones
that be potentially made into single
variety ciders and that's kind of
something it's kind of like a holy grail
of cider production right because most
of ciders that you have and certainly
this one here has a mix of from from Eve
cider II as a mix of probably 10 plus
different apple varieties in here so
trying to understand you know what these
are a lot of these are that are way out
here are the species but even some of
these in here and so if we can find
apples that have the juice quality but
also have the horticultural aspects that
we're looking for for cider production
that would be great we've been working
with the metabolomics facility also to
screen so
varieties for there thank you for their
polyphenol content and we found some
really interesting things so this is
Kingston black is highlighted and so
that's this Apple here and this is a
bitter sharp it is a terrible Apple to
grow it's probably one of the worst
apples I've ever seen horticulturally in
terms of the tree structure it kind of
grows like this pear it doesn't produce
very much fruit but it's been talked
about for hundreds of years in the
literature as being one of the best
cider apples right so it doesn't grow
well it's very difficult to grow but has
the the juice quality in the cider
quality that the producers keep talking
about and so what is it about it that
makes it so special well it has this
this subset of polyphenols these hydro
oxi cinematic acids which kind of lend
themselves to these smoky notes and
insiders and that's kind of been
something that adds a lot of depth and
character to the to the to the cider
sand so you know kind of understand that
has been really interesting we've been
working with Kentucky's lab also we're
taking that collection of fruit and
we're doing some genotyping so this is
using some of his of kananga's acidity
genes and so you know traditionally
apples were classified based on their
chemical composition as I've talked
about we're trying to see if we can come
up with a genetic way of of classifying
apples right based on genes which would
be really helpful to have these markers
for breeding programs going through 300
sessions in the germ plasm collection
you know doing all this other things
that I'm doing which is very slow and
time-consuming if we had some genetic
markers would be fantastic so our next
up is try to work on the polyphenols
which is a lot more complicated from a
molecular level because polyphenols are
upregulated from so many different
biotic and abiotic sources so a lot of
my work has been on you know what are
the pre harvest and and in some cases
post harvest management influences that
would affect the quality of the cider so
kind of this laundry list of things that
we
looking at a lot of these have been
studied for wine grapes and dessert
apples but a lot less so for cider
apples right there has not been a whole
lot of research in cider apples
particularly in the u.s. historically
just because there was no real reason to
this is really good cider so we looked
at crop load so crop load affects so
many different aspects of the tree and
you can see low medium and high is being
shown here and what we found was that in
the fermented cider that the high crop
load which had smaller sized fruit had
the highest phenolic content in the
fermented cider we didn't see it in the
juice but we did see it in the fermented
cider which is interesting and so we've
had a couple of follow up projects on
that to try to understand that more this
is David sue colic here and so we've
been looking at this issue more closely
for the past several years at a
commercial farm up in in Lyndonville New
York and trying to tease apart you know
not just one variety but we're looking
at seven different cultivars some
interesting trends we found so far is
that as fruit weight increased you had
larger fruit we had higher phenolic
content so it's a lot of you know now
we're kind of going whoa it's kind of
different data than what we saw before
we're trying to make heads or tails of
what's happening in amongst you know
their genetic differences or
environmental what are the specifics
that are causing these differences and
so Lindsay Springer is a postdoc in my
lab now has a series of projects to
really try to break this apart and try
to understand this phenomenon because
we're getting such contradictory data
back I mentioned about storing apples in
cold storage and we actually are finding
a positive benefit to that and so it's
kind of four different time points is
what we're looking at in the different
color bars and two different varieties
definite and Bonet Rouge and we see an
increase in all these phenolic contents
after storage so while not
widely in the rest of the world there
could be a benefit to it and that some
of these phenolic compounds are
polymerized in the in the fruit as they
age you have a whole bunch of projects
that we're looking at in terms of
nitrogen cycle in the orchard and and
just for the sake of time I'm just going
to say if you want to learn more about
that come talk to me but we're looking
at it the orchard level the fermentation
level it's a really important issue in
cider because apples have a very low
nitrogen content which leads to hydrogen
sulfide production a rotten egg smell an
obvious flaw for for most consumers and
so we've been spending a lot of time and
effort rennet tease that apart if you
drive around 366 we have this new
experimental orchard out there for cider
apple cider apples its high density
system with the goal of trying to do
something like using over the real
harvester so this is an experimental
over the real harvester that was I came
across in the UK so they're thinking
about it too and trying to get fruit off
of the tree as opposed to off of the
ground
so do teach a class about this we have a
hundred students enrolled in our
undergraduate cider production class
right now which is really fantastic we
also do a lab where students get to do
the fermentation we've done some fun
projects last year we did we had them go
into Wikipedia the whole Wikipedia entry
for cider was subpar
in my opinion so hopefully we made it
better with our students and not worse
but they learned how to go in and do
editing in Wikipedia I worked and if
you've been in Mann library lately it's
been up there for a long time worked
with them to digitize and at Simon Ignis
here he did a lot of the digitization
for us in this project we digitized
a lot of old texts about apples and
p'malee G and insight and and cider
which is beautiful they get posted on
the biodiversity heritage library but
it's also been important from a
scientific perspective because we have a
lot of missing varieties in our in the
in the US right now and so we're able to
go back and look at Fox welp here from
1811
from the air for sure Pomona and then
compared to the example that's in the
USDA collection clearly not the same so
some final thoughts there's a lot of
potential we don't have very much in the
way of acreage here yet but you know
it's increasing I know right now I
showed a picture earlier of Phil in
front of a nursery and apple tree
nursery and in that nursery alone about
ten percent of all that they're growing
is for cider apples so thousands of new
cider apple trees are being made each
year and a lot of hittin the ground and
so we're working with harvest New York
to just try to get a sense of how big
it's getting and and where it's going
and another note is while cider has been
great I've also got my eye on Perry so
the third one you had to taste is
actually a fermented pear and so this is
made by Tom Oliver in the UK if you
still have some in your glass one of the
interesting things about pears is that
they produce a lot of sorbitol and a lot
more than apples do and so sorbitol is a
non fermentable sugar and so it leaves a
natural residual sweetness in the
product so I think it's delicious so I
work with a large group we've got a lot
of information on our website and you
know go visit that and come talk to me
and they got one or two minutes for
questions done No so in that study about
about storing the apples and the
increase in phenology over time those
were hand harvested very well treated
apples not like the ones I showed
earlier in the in the lecture today yeah
Alan
yeah so the question is about like
entero pathogenic organisms like
hatchling and e.coli no because he
apples even though they probably when
they're going into the mill have these
organisms on them there's a number of
different kill steps they concentrate
the juice up to like 75 80 percent sugar
content which is a kill step it's a heat
process they use pasteurization
sometimes before fermentation and then
definitely after fermentation and
they'll also use like sterile filtration
through like a point four or five micron
filter so they have these different kill
steps it's different on the craft end of
the industry where there's a lot less
control and a lot less kill steps so
there is a concern but the kill step
there is really the alcohol content and
that most of these organisms are not
able to live in a low alcohol solution
or the the toxins they produce or broken
down during the actual you know process
of fermentation so there's actually
really nice paper put out by some
colleagues at WSU in the December issue
of court technology addressing this
Geneva questions you're good okay it's a
great question so the question is why is
it a holy grail for the cider industry
to have these single-variety ciders and
to be able to put Kingston black cider
on their label
I don't know exactly but um it you know
I think it's because of the us wine
industry and because so many wines are
marketed as Riesling or Pinot Noir or
you know by the variety name and so it
kind of has been and it's not just our
current producers in the u.s. it's you
go back and read some of this old
literature that we were scanning in and
they talked about you know how this this
variety makes this excellent single
variety cider yeah I mean I think you
know I think there is a marketing angle
to it from a production standpoint and
certainly from the growers perspective
you're absolutely right right more
varieties means diversity which means
you have crop failure or an off year and
one variety you'll have something else
to fill in the gap and if you're
depending on that one variety and you
don't have it that year for whatever
reason it's a difficult marketing
strategy to have not the not the younger
consumers yeah interesting horde quest
[Laughter]
but with actually longer so okay so
Marvin's asked a couple questions about
Applejack first is how strong does it
get in terms of alcohol content I don't
know exactly I would say you probably
get two to three times their initial
concentration so I guess somewhere in
the 20s to 30 percent ABV alcohol by
volume would be my guess but I've never
made it and don't know and you know in
terms of historically Applejack was
widely consumed pre Prohibition era
because it was a cheap source of of high
you know high proof booze essentially
and so in fact a lot of the temperance
move
was a was in reaction to the consumption
of Applejack because not only was it
cheap and there was a lot of it around
but because of these other alcohols that
were in the product it was you know had
a lot of negative health impacts and so
yeah that's the story of people used to
go blind and certainly probably a lot of
people became alcoholic from drinking
cheap Applejack historically my mother
was a member of the women's this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu